To see the key value pairs that are stored
for a particular site or scheme host port combination, you
can open up the chrome developer tool, go to
the Resources tab and select Local storage. Note that there
is Local storage which persists across reloads and sessions
storage which has the same API but it's isolated by
tab and it's cleared at the end of the session.
So whenever the page is closed down, the Sessions Storage
goes away. Now, remember, you can only store text
in local storage, so if you wanted to store
an image or some other binary data type, you'd
have to first base64 and code it. And of
course, you only get typically about 5MB per domain,
so you're not going to be able to store very
much. So now it's your turn. Use local storage
to store the value "bar" for the key "foo"